[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug bachelor president and
Speaker of amazing
facts Hello friends would you like to
hear an amazing fact in 2006 Petaluma
California Animal Control workers were
called to investigate a home where a
neighbor had reported a terrible smell
when they knocked on the door of
67-year-old Roger deer they expected to
find a hord of cats or something instead
they found 1,000 pet rats ranging from
giant adults to baby pink babies all
sharing this one room house with their
owner deer kept most of a small rodent
friends in about 20 huge cages that used
lined up around the house the animal
service manager said that a number of
his rats were also allowed to run free
the infestation began when this
soft-hearted owner took pity on a couple
of baby rats he planned to feed to his
pet python you know that a pair of rats
can produce as many as 2,000 descendants
in a year if left to breed unchecked
that's why the Bible says big problems
can grow out of very small Beginnings
stay with us friends we're going to
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions our phone lines are now open
if you have a Bible related question
call us at 1 1800 God says that's 1800
7297 now let's join our host Pastor Doug
Bachelor and our co-host Pastor Jean
Ross welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you've never tuned
in before this is a live International
interactive Bible study you can
participate by calling in with your
Bible questions now is a great time
we've got lines wide open give us a call
with a Bible question we'll do our best
to find the answers in the word of God
we've got uh the Bible on our computers
here in several different uh formats
where we can quickly search things we've
even got the original Greek and Hebrew
just uh pick up your phone here's the
number 800 God says it's 800 463 7297
one more time the phone number into the
studio 800 463
7297 and I'm Doug Bachelor my name is
Johan Ross good evening listening frams
and pass Doug as always let's start the
program with prayer dear Father in
heaven we thank you that we have this
opportunity to open your word and study
together we want to ask the Holy Spirit
to come and guide our hearts our minds
thank you Father that if we search you
will lead in Jesus name amen amen Pastor
D you open the program by talking about
this uh
incredible sort of just onslaught of
rats and not only were they there
unwillingly it was they were nured and
fed and taken care of by this very
soft-hearted individual you can just
imagine one or two rats in the house but
to have how many rats did he have he had
a thousand rat rats in a one room house
now I believe it because uh when I was a
kid in New York my brother and I talked
my mother into letting us have some pet
mice and again when our kids were little
they wanted pet mice and so we gave them
an aquarium one aquarium and let them
get a couple of mice and it is amazing
how quickly they can multiply and pretty
soon we were taking little boxes of mice
to the pet store trying to sell them
back we couldn't hardly give them away
so uh yeah they can
proliferate uh
exponentially and you know there's a
scripture in the Bible that talks about
how something small if if it's not uh
monitored can totally get out of hand in
James 3:5 it says even so the tongue
though it is little among the members
the organs in the body and it boasts
great things see how great a matter a
little fire Kindles in other words see
how a whole Forest can burn from a match
is what James is saying here and U
sometimes we don't appreciate the power
of little things like our words a couple
of words kind words spoken to encourage
can turn a person's life around I can
tell you several stories from history
where a person their genius was inspired
because someone gave them a little bit
of encouragement and likewise others
have been terribly discouraged by just a
few careless or unkind words maybe you
have been the victim of some reckless
gossip and um if you'd like to know what
the Bible says about this subject we
have a free offer and it's called tiny
troublemakers tell us about that Pastor
Ross if you'd like to receive this book
just give us a call on our resource
phone number the number is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the book called
tiny troublemakers and we'll be sends to
anybody who calls and asks so that phone
number again this is the resource phone
phone line is
6747 ask for the book tiny troublemakers
and if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio is
7297 that number again is 800 463
7297 we're going to go to our first
caller this evening we have Diana
listening from Washington Diana welome
welcome to the
program thank you Pastor Doug bless your
heart for the work you do for Jesus well
thank you and thank you for calling well
I'm closer to God in large part due to
your ministry so thank you to you too
say um I wish I had pen and paper and
wrote it down once but I heard you say
once about a method for reading the
Bible and I did look online but it's not
the one that's online um but you
mentioned a method that makes it a
little bit easier to get through
especially the parts that are not quite
so easy to get through well I've got a
few formulas I I can I'll try a couple
of them and see if anything rings a bell
is that what you wanted me to do well
the one I only heard you say one and the
one online is kind of a little bit
dissected the continuity isn't there for
me and it was like two verses here and
then two verses in another book of the
Bible and end them per day you know two
verses in another book of the Bible but
that to me wouldn't give me the
continuity I would like to have yeah
well what I've sometimes recommended uh
you know Martin Luther said you should
read the Bible the way you pick apples
where first you shake the whole tree and
then you shake the branches and you look
behind the leaves and you shake the
Twigs um it's good to get kind of the
history because in the New Testament 10%
of Everything Jesus said he's quoting
from the Old Testament so having the Old
Testament history but some of it you
know you get into some of the Chron
ologies and the numbers can get pretty
dry until you start studying that and so
what I found is helpful is a person go
ahead and read Genesis through chapter
50 read Exodus uh like 1 to2 where it
talks about them beginning their Journey
Through the
Wilderness uh and then you can actually
go to um if you read the story of Joshua
Judges first and 2 Samuel 1 and 2 Kings
now doing that you've got the Bible
History you don't have to read 1 and 2
Chronicles right away that is a little
bit of a repeat of first and second
Kings so uh with that and then you jump
to the New Testament so you're getting
the history then as you back up and you
read some of the Major Prophets like
Ezekiel Jeremiah and then you read the
Minor Prophets when Jesus and the
apostles are quoting from the prophecies
you'll say Ah that's what they mean so
when you go to the New Testament you
read Matthew Mark Luke John and acts
that gives you the
history and so I find for me I I like to
know the history of the Bible story and
that kind of gives you the whole history
and it you're only reading about a third
of the Bible when you do it that way
your first time through then you go back
and you delve into the other
books I think this is what I heard you
say before and I did read the Bible
through one time but it took me a long
time and I don't want to take that long
this time that sounds really that sounds
really good now you know what I do is uh
every morning I wake up I read the Bible
and I'm always reading through the Bible
I've got software so that while I'm
reading it it is reading it out loud to
me while I'm looking at the words so I'm
not only seeing it with my eyes I'm
hearing someone who's got perfect bible
pronunciation read it and that helps
because there's sometimes difficult
names and places in the Bible and U hey
you know we have a resource we can give
you that talks more about that and it's
called the ultimate resource talking
about Bible reading we'll be happy to
send you a free copy Diana all you'll
have to do is just give us a call on our
resource phone line and that's 8835 6747
you can ask for the book called The
Ultimate resource and we'll send it out
to you for free or anyone who calls you
can also read the book online at
amazingfacts.org our next call is
Ricardo listening from California
Ricardo welcome to the
program hi Ricardo you're on the air
hi hi uh oh you cut me off okay uh thank
you for for taking my call I'm calling
about Acts chapter uh 6 verse 8 okay uh
people in my sphere of
influence have a problem with the Holy
Spirit and uh I noticed because you know
we had a conversation we had a a bit of
a difference so I got home I looked at
the new King James version of Acts
chapter 6:8 and it mentioned that the
the Holy Spirit it didn't even mention
the Holy Spirit what it said was um it
was uh full of faith and
power say it again it says he was full
of faith and power yes so my question is
is um is this just the baset of the Holy
Spirit or they or is somebody the Bible
writers uh Taking Liberties with the
Holy
Spirit no when it when it says that he
is full of Faith uh when you have faith
and that faith can translate into room
in your life for the Holy Spirit to work
I don't think it's talking about him
having power by himself he was full of
faith and power of the spirit is what I
think is
assumed and because he goes on and he
does signs and wonders he's doing
Miracles and that's always by the power
of God's spirit no man is doing
that that's that's to benefit the church
and and you know bring people closer to
God yeah you know there's another verse
I'm just looking at Acts 1:8 you'll see
the connection between power and the
Holy Spirit Jesus said but you shall
receive power when the Holy Spirit has
come upon
you yes Stephen being filled with power
and here Jesus says that you will
receive power when you have the Holy
Spirit yeah good
point so I don't know if that helps a
little we do have a a book Ricardo we
could send you a free copy that talks
about life in the spirit
and um it may not address this verse
particularly but it does talk about what
it means to be Spirit-filled we I think
yeah we have that book and there's one
other I thought of uh dealing with the
subject of the Holy Spirit and that's
called the Trinity so you can just call
and ask for those books and we'll be
happy to send it to you Ricardo or
anybody who wants to learn more about
what the Bible has to say about the Holy
Spirit the phone line to call is
8835 6747 you can ask for the book
called life in the spirit
and while you at it ask for the book on
the Trinity just called the Trinity and
we'll be Happ to send that to anybody
who calls and asks thank you for your
call Ricardo our next caller is Let's
see we have Phillip or Phil rather
listening from uh New York Phil welcome
to the program yeah how you doing can
you hear me okay loud and clear okay
great you're doing a great job my qu my
question is this thank you very much for
taking my call my question when Trump
was in Moscow he and Putin apparently
agreed that Assad would remain in power
in Syria that means that the Russian
Iran Iranian Alliance will now control
Iraq Syria and Lebanon and substantially
surround Israel so my question is are we
seeing biblical
prophecy in today's newspapers is this
the beginning of the war of Gog and
MOG you know some have wondered if uh
and of course now we're delving into
some uh Bible prophecy and you know
Jesus said when these things come to
pass then you will know meaning
prophecies always best understood
looking backwards um there are some
prophecies in Daniel
11 where it seems to suggest that at
some point the the nation of Israel is
going to be surrounded by hostile
neighbors um and then you can read where
Luke I think it's chapter 21 where Jesus
said Jerusalem will be trotten down of
the Gentiles until the times of the
Gentiles be fulfilled and so some have
seen what's happening politically and
wonder if you know uh steps are being
put in place for a um where there could
be a showdown of some sort you know I
don't know um that's been predicted
since 1948 to the present and so far
everybody's kind of missed that
prediction so I want to be careful not
to be uh saying that this is this is
what's happening politically now
um it is
unnerving that you do see the whole
religious landscape of the world
changing from where you know right now
there's technically a Christian majority
in the world but by um I think it's
2025 I think Muslims are going to be the
number one religion in the world and so
and knowing that some feel very hostile
towards Christians that could lead to
another war that would be a religious
War
okay thank you very much for your
consideration you're doing a great job
and it means a lot to me thank you very
much sir thank you for calling Phil
appreciate your call now uh I'm trying
to think we I've got a series that we
just did you can watch online for free
and it's called um Israel Islam and
Christianity and
prophecy and I'm I'm yeah I think it
might be posted yeah it's at the Granda
Bay website it is that's right yeah you
can go to the uh Granite Bay uh website
to view that or just go to the Amazing
Facts website and type in is Israel
Islam and prophecy and you can order the
whole series yeah there at the store
thanks your call Phil our next call is
Seth and he's listening uh Seth's
listening in Hope Michigan Seth welcome
to the program hi hi um um I was calling
with the question about 1 Timothy 1
verse 20 it says of whom are hus and
Alexander who whom I delivered to Satan
that they may learn not to blashe and I
was wondering why Paul would deliver
them Satan so that they could learn not
to blashe when Satan would be the one
blaspheming attempting them to blashe
well God blesses and protects us and
when himonas and Alexander rejected the
truth and gave Paul a very hard time
Paul basically said look I'm not going
to intercede for God to bless you uh
you're going to just end up on Satan's
territory and after you find out how
difficult Satan is to serve you may
learn that it's not good to blaspheme
God um several times through history
when God's people would turn from him he
would let them be beat up by their
enemies this happened with Israel and
Assyria with Judah and Babylon and
different kingdoms when they would turn
from God the moabites the Philistines
the would come in and beat them
up and then theyd turn back to God Paul
is basically saying he's going to do the
same thing with these two characters
that had been um uh BL fing and giving
the church a hard time he's going to say
Lord don't bless them let the devil beat
them up so that they'll realize that
they need to turn back to
you oh
okay okay thank you is that your
understanding Pastor Ross yeah
absolutely when somebody rejects God's
protection where you open your yourself
up to the devil and uh that what that's
what was happening here it seems hey we
appreciate your question thanks so much
next call is Ronald do from Bronx New
York Ronald welcome to the
program hello hi Ronald thank you for
calling yeah uh I like to know um what
what happens to a teenager when he dies
because there are some
teenagers that are doing some horrible
sins and is is it possible for a
teenager to go to hell you know because
of the age accountability you know well
there's only there it's a very important
question it's also a very troubling
question there are two Destinies there's
there's no third Destiny it's either
life or death uh God says either we get
uh eternal life we're covered by the
blood of the Lamb we receive forgiveness
and we're in heaven or we pay for our
own sins now if a young person dies
before the age of accountability where
they really understand the consequences
of right or wrong or if they grow up in
such a way where they just really don't
understand faith in God uh God factors
all that in their
judgment and so you know what that age
is I think the age of accountability
varies with different children uh you
and I have known people Ronald that
because of maybe some mental problem
they you can have a grown adult that
acts like a child and they never
understand because they just they're
mentally challenged and some are very
you know it's the the same question is
how old should a child be before they're
baptized you want to make sure that
they're old enough to understand the
claims of the gospel and the difference
of right and wrong I heard one Pastor
say well if they're old enough to be
lost they're old enough to be saved and
uh so um it is troubling sometimes you
hear about teenagers they do some pretty
difficult things and or they you know
die by Suicide and everyone wonders will
they be
saved now some people misunderstand what
happens to the
lost and and you
know you're you'll hear preachers
that'll say that you know a teenager
dies from a suicide and God puts him in
hell right after death and burns them
there for ceaseless ages that go on
through ever and ever now you think
about that a billion years from now
they're still burning that's not what
the Bible
teaches uh the Bible teaches that people
get punished according to what they
deserve and it says they are consumed
they are burnt up they perish they're
ashes uh there's a lot of very clear
verses on that so and we have a free
lesson we'll be happy to send you on
that Ronald now so
um you still there news I was reading
the Del news where there was a teenage
guy he killed himself because um he
figured nobody loved him you know I know
that's tragic when we hear things like
that yeah and I was thinking I was
saying he's in the Lord's hand you know
now you know cuz he was hurt you know
killed as he ground himself you know
yeah that's heartbreaking when you hear
those things and you know as a pastor
I've had to do funerals for young people
that took their own lives and and uh it
is it's just a very difficult situation
all you could do is put them in God's
hands and uh know that God loves people
more than we do but you know we'll be
happy to send you that study guide that
explains what is the punishment of the
wicked and that's the part that people
really misunderstand and it's called is
the devil in charge of of Hell the
number to call is 8835 6747 you can ask
for the study guide called is the devil
in charge of Hell we'll be happy to send
this to anybody who calls and asks if
you have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is
7297 it's 800 463
7297 our next call is Mike and he's
listening from New Mexico Mike welcome
to Bible answers
live hi thank you for talking to me
tonight I had a question about uh what
exactly Jesus meant when he said you say
you are of the father but you are truly
the synagogue of Satan and how does that
relate to us living
today all right well the word synagogue
when Jesus talked about being of the
synagogue of Satan by the way that's
found in Revelation as well um that just
means church or
gathering um and there are people who
were saying you know we're we're part of
God's church but they're really doing
the work of the devil they were
persecuting Christ they were persecuting
the apostles they were getting together
and Jesus said you you make long prayers
and then you devour widows houses
meaning you you take all the money of
the poor widows but you pray long
prayers and he said that's not the
church that's the synagogue of Satan
that does things like that or you pray
to be seen of men or when you give an
offering you blow the trumpet so
everyone will see it uh when you fast
you advertise it so that people will be
proud of how holy you are all that is
from the synagogue of Satan it's the
synagogue of Pride selfishness greed
yeah the verse you're looking at there
is revelation 2:9 where it talks about
the synagogue of Satan and then also in
Revelation 3:9 same phrase is used yeah
Jesus told the scribes and Pharisees
says you're of the your father the devil
that's right so all in the same vein
Mike you still there Jesus seems yes I
am Jesus seems to like it when people
are just reserved D and quiet yet he
wants us to spread the gospel around the
world to all who will hear it but he
wants us to pray quietly and not make a
big deal out of things he said that we
need to be bold and humble meaning when
it comes to telling someone else the way
of Salvation Brave outspoken that's why
Jesus said let your light so shine
before men that they may see your good
works and glorify your father not
glorify you but at the same time uh
Believers need to be humble he said when
you give don't let your left hand know
what your right hand is doing when you
pray enter into your closet and pray
don't make a spectacle doesn't mean it's
ever wrong to pray in front or in front
of people because Jesus did but you
shouldn't pray to be seen of
men that make sense I just discovered
your show it sure does I'm going to
listen to your show uh more I put this
channel on my presets and I'm really
glad I found it tonight well bless your
heart thank you for the endorsement and
tell all your friends and enemies as
well appreciate that Mike I will that
all right God
bless next call is Neil listening from
Seattle Washington Neil welcome to the
program hi what what did Jesus mean when
he said Upon This Rock I'll build my
church Peter the rock well actually it's
not Peter if you look at that statement
in the original Greek uh Jesus said you
well first of all he said who do men say
that I am and some of the disciples said
well some say you're Moses some say
Elijah Jeremiah one of the other
prophets and Jesus said who do you say
that I am and Peter is the one who spoke
up and he said you are the Christ the
son of the Living God and Jesus said
Flesh and Blood did not reveal that unto
you but my Father which is in heaven and
he said I say unto you your name is
Peter and the word Peter there in Greek
it means a pebble the Rolling Stone like
you'd find in a creek but on this Petra
he said but on this rock
I will build my church The Rock on which
Jesus is building the church was not
Peter uh it was actually the statement
of Peter that he was the Christ as the
Messiah because you read a little
further in the same chapter and I forget
that's Matthew 16 Matthew 16 you read a
little later in the same chapter and
Jesus says to Peter get behind me Satan
so we would hope that Jesus is not
building this church on someone that a
few minutes later and that's verse
Matthew
16:23 he turned turned to Peter and said
get behind me Satan you're an offense to
me you're not mindful of the things of
God that's immediately after he says on
this Rock I'm going to build my church
evidently Peter didn't uh think of
himself as being the foundation of the
church because you read in Acts where
Peter got up and preached he spoke of
Jesus being the Cornerstone of the
church Jesus being uh the rock him being
the foundation so in Peter's mind he
understood that the fact that Jesus is
the Christ that's the foundation upon
which the church is built
it's not
denominational no it's the church that
Jesus now that doesn't mean Jesus
doesn't have a truth and there are some
people that believe it and some don't
believe it but uh I don't think Christ
was speaking of for example the Catholic
church when he made that statement you
know our Roman Catholic friends would
very strong yeah and it talked basically
about how that that the Catholic church
was the rock that P built and the rest
is not and so I wondered when did it
change and what how to think about it
yeah that well you're asking the right
question Jesus never meant by that
statement that he was building the
church on Peter he meant I'm going to
build the church on the Declaration that
Peter made that I am the Messiah and
that's it hey thank you very much and um
trying to think we've got uh the search
for the true church yeah that would be a
great resource the number to call for
that is 800 83567 47 and uh Neil take a
look at the book called The search for
the true church I think you'll find that
very interesting I'll send you a free
copy just call that number again that
number is 800 835
6747 now we're reaching the bottom of
the hour we're going to take a brief
break but we do still have some lines
open now if you call and the phone may
ring a minute but uh he that endures to
the end your call will be taken because
we do have operators here that number
again if you want to make your phone
call is 800 this brings your questions
into the studio from around the country
800 God says that's 8004
63729 7 and we're going to come back
with more Bible questions so don't go
very far and um don't forget the website
U we can do the Live program just for
one hour during the week but 24 hours a
day you could be streaming and beaming
amazing facts television and a lot of
other information coming right
back stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a
moment are you wondering what lies ahead
in human history landmarks of Prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by Pastor
Doug Bachelor landmarks of Prophecy is a
video Bible study Adventure designed for
today's audiences presenting The
Landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your epic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of Prophecy today by calling
8005382583
[Music]
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation bible.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit the amazing Bible
timeline at
bible.com stay tuned Bible answers live
will return in a
moment are you wondering what lies ahead
in human history landmarks of Prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by Pastor
Doug Bachelor landmarks of Prophecy as a
video Bible study Adventure designed for
today's audiences presenting The
Landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your epic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of Prophecy today by calling
85387 275 or by visiting AF
bookstore.com
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aftv.org at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day 7 days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo do from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation
bible.com is a free resource where you
can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's word go
deeper visit the amazing Bible timeline
at
[Music]
bible.com every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers
live this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 83567
47 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's join pastors Doug
Bachelor and Jean Ross for more Bible
answers
live welcome back listening friend to
Bible answers live and if you've joined
us along the way it is a live
International Bible study and you can
call in with your Bible questions 800
46372 N7 free phone call in North
America
and my name is Doug Bachelor my name is
Johan Ross and we're going to go
straight back to the phone lines we have
Steve who is listening from Georgia
Steve welome to the program thank you
very much Pastor Doug and Sir um I keep
the Commandments and have the testimony
of Jesus which that of course includes
the seventh day Sabbath so I had a
question in regard to uh Isaiah
584 where he says I'm short in a prayer
of faith uh uh Delight thyself in the
Lord and I will cause thee to ride upon
the high places of the
Earth yeah are you wondering what is
meant by the high places of the Earth
yeah because I want to do that yeah well
that's actually talking about um uh you
know that you would just uh live a life
in the uh Glory you know they often
talked about whoever has the high place
usually had the place of Defense go
ahead Pastor Ross you know I think a
clue is to that also he's in the very
next part of the verse it says' and I'll
feed you with the heritage of Jacob your
father now uh you know the the ultimate
reward for the righteous Jesus said the
meek shall inherit the earth and in
Hebrews it talks about Abraham who was
looking for a city whose Builder makeer
was God so Abraham understood and Jacob
understood that the little piece of land
there in the Middle East Palestine isn't
their final home but for the redeemed
their home is going to be the world made
new and that's the promise so talks
about riding on the high heels of the
earth and inheriting uh the reward that
God promised to Jacob uh that's talking
ultimately about the Earth recreated
that you read about in Revelation chap
21 mhm if you read in Deuteronomy
3213 here Moses is talking about it's
his final message to Israel and it says
he made him ride on the high places of
the land he ate the produce of the field
he suckled with the honey out of the
Rock and out of the flinty Rocks so like
Pastor Ross was saying it was talking
about the blessings of the land would be
given well when there was war if you had
The High Ground you were usually the
winner and so it's just talking about
God will bless you with the advantages
and the blessings and uh yeah it's not
like the high places in the 60s that was
something
else well you know I love the part about
the high places uh of of the earth as
the best defense because we serve the
most high you know so we're more than
conquerors
that's right good point and uh we hope
that those listening can experience
riding on the high places of the earth
hey thank you very much for your call
Steve our next call is Peter listening
from Canada Peter welcome to the program
yeah hello hi Mr Russ Pastor Russ good
yeah so I have a question on um
Revelation Chapter 14 verse 6
okay you want us to read that for people
listening if he would so
yeah to yeah well because others
listening good part of our audience is
driving down the road and I want them to
hear what we're talking about Revelation
14:6 then I saw another Angel flying in
the midst of Heaven having the
Everlasting gospel to preach to those
who dwell on the earth to Every Nation
tribe tongue and people so what's your
question on that is that speaking of
this world to come or Another World this
world see Jesus said to the disciples
when he went to heaven go preach the
gospel to All
Nations and so here before Christ comes
Revelation 14 what is it Pastor us verse
14 where Jesus comes MH and verse 14 it
says I look and behold a white cloud and
one sat on the cloud like the son of man
so verse 14 pictures the second coming
verse 6 is talking about the gospel
going to the whole world before the
second coming Jesus said in Matthew 24
when the gospel is preached in all the
world then the end will come so the
mission for Christians is to get the
gospel around the world of course that's
what amazing facts is trying to do and
then the Lord comes also it's
interesting to note obviously Revelation
is filled with symbols uh in Bible
prophecies angels are sometimes
symbolized or or are used the symbols
representing Messengers The Original
Greek word for Angel is angalo which
means Messer and when you have these
Three Angels here in Revelation chap 14
it represents a message being taken by
God's people and proclaimed around the
world to Every Nation Kindred tongue and
people so this is a great proclamation
of God's last warning message calling
people to worship God as the Creator
just before probation closes and Jesus
comes I appreciate your answer all right
hey Peter well thank you very much and
appreciate your question you know we
have a study guide dealing specifically
with the Three Angels messages we'll be
happy to send this to you Peter or
anybody wanting to learn and by the way
this is a very important prophecy that
you find right here in Revelation
chapter 14 we really encourage folks to
call and ask for the study guide It's
called angel messages from space angel
messages from space the number to call
is 8835 6747 and ask for the study guide
on the Three Angels messages or Angel
message from space we'll be happy to
send it to anybody who calls and asks or
you can read it for free online at
amazingfacts.org our next caller that we
have is uh let's see we have an
listening from Michigan uh an welcome to
the program hello hi an you're on the
air thank you and your question tonight
well my question is how is it where in
the Bible does it say that Islam is a
hostile religion you said that when you
were speaking about the prophecies in
the Bible coming to pass dealing with
Iraq and everything that's going on in
Syria and Lebanon and you also made the
statement that you know Islam is a
hostile
no well first of all if I said that uh I
don't remember saying that uh I said
there are nations that are hostile to
Israel and I was talking about
prophecies in Daniel 11 there is no
prophecy about Islam in the Bible
because Islam did not exist until 700
years after Christ so you're not going
to find um a statement in the Bible that
says the word Islam because the word
wasn't even known in when the Bible was
complete there are prophecies that talk
about Nations and if you look in Daniel
CH 11 it'll talk about Egypt Libya Moab
Edom Ammon Syria Ethiopia which is you
know partially Christian and Muslim and
so there were Nations that are mentioned
that today are predominantly Muslim um
there's actually there's actually
prophecies in Isaiah no it's
predominantly Islam Muslim is a person
one who submits to the will of God Islam
is a religion which means peace the
religion of Peace So cities or countries
that are Islam not Muslim right because
Muslim would be the person one who
practices the religion of Peace are you
a Christian I'm not I was Christian up
until a few years ago do you mind my
asking what is your religion now my
religion now is Islam the religion of
Peace how do you feel about uh in your
religion about the nation of Israel to
be honest I'm not familiar with what's
going on across East because there's a
battle here where I'm at with peace
among our own people in this country and
the police and everywhere else yeah
everything else so I I don't know about
the tragedies that's happening in Israel
because I'm African-American I have a
war in my own country not against the
police just not being targeted by police
right and not being targeted by people
who hate religion because I put a scarf
over my head and you know and I want to
be friendly to my and know my neighbor
who the left of me and the right of me
well obviously there there is no there's
no reason to be offended by a person's
religion because of a modest dress
custom so if people don't like a
religion because they grow a beard or
they cover their hair that's a pretty
puny reason to be unhappy with
somebody's religion um I think you would
agree with me
that there are some who come from the
faith of
Muhammad that Advocate
violence I don't believe that to be true
you you don't agree with it but you
admit that there are some who say at
least that they are Muslims who Advocate
violence no because the religion is
peace like that's what the word is I
know that's what the word means but I'm
saying you would admit there are some
who claim to be Muslims who Advocate
violence claim yes who claim yes but to
be practicing to be a practicing Muslim
is not to be violent so yes I would say
that there are some who claim to be
Muslim and Advocate violence just there
just like there are some who claim to be
Christian and advoc that's right you
know VI yeah and I would say the same
thing that you're probably saying I'd
say that any true Christian would never
support that that you know the religion
of Jesus obviously he's called The
Prince of Peace well hey I thank you for
calling and I I hope that cleared things
up a little bit you might enjoy the
series that I recently produced that's
called Christianity and Islam in
Prophecy now there are prophecies that
talk about uh these nations you can for
instance you can find the origin of
Ishmael and it talks about that in the
Bible but the word Muslim wasn't used
back then you would enjoy that and I
appreciate your calling an thank you
thank you for calling our next caller is
uh let's see we've got uh Robert
listening from Washington Robert welcome
to the program hi there Pastor Doug and
Pastor Ross hey thank you for calling
yes I had a question about the New
Covenant somebody was telling me uh
online that was that the New Covenant
that Jesus puts in our hearts is the law
of Love Not The Ten Commandments and so
how would a person tell the other person
that it's the Ten Commandments not just
quote the law of Love well one thing you
can do is just explain that uh Paul says
uh love is the fulfilling of the law in
other words if you are really loving
your neighbor you're going to keep the
Ten Commandments The Ten Commandments
spell out love if you love your neighbor
you're obviously not going to lie to him
or kill him or steal from him and so and
the same thing with loving God if you
love God you're not going to use his
name irreverently you're going to want
to spend time with him during the holy
time appointments he's made and you're
going to want to um uh you not going to
insult him by making images so you go
through the Ten Commandments and and
they're all about love for God and love
for your fellow man but they're not
displac the New Covenant is I will write
the law Ten Commandments in the heart
meaning love will be the motive for
keeping them does that make sense that
makes sense yeah and you know we do
actually have uh a lesson that I think
you'd enjoy Robert that's called uh
written in
stone and it talks about the New
Covenant and talks about law of love and
we also have that book does God's grace
blot out the law talks about the
covenants to receive that call us on our
resource phone line that's 8835
6747 you can ask for the book called
does God's grace blot out the law and
also ask for the study guide called
written in stone and we'll be happy to
send it to anybody who calls and asks is
800 um 835
6747 our next caller that we have is uh
Carol listening from Oakland California
Carol welcome to the program hi I had a
question about uh Christmas decorations
my mother studied uh for a little while
with the Jehovah Witness when I was a a
little girl and I don't know if that's
why I've always since felt kind of
uneasy about having decorations and I
just thought I should just get that you
know straightened out in my mind because
I know it says in the Bible that if you
think something's wrong then you
shouldn't do it if you have I guess that
means if you have a personal conviction
and it's not right to you so I just
wanted to ask your opinion on that my I
have a friend also who says it she
doesn't believe in celebrating Christmas
because she believes that there's a a
section in the Bible that says something
about a tree and yeah they're reading
Jeremiah what is it chapter 10 I I think
Pastor Ross is going to look it up for
people have read that CH that prophecy
in Jeremiah and they said it's a
Christmas tree and it's not at all
talking about a Christmas tree uh you
can read it and see where people get the
idea but back to your earlier question
there is no command in the Bible that
you need to remember Christmas there's
no command in the Bible that even tells
us the date of jesus' birthday or that
it should be celebrated um and in Romans
you read where you know one man regards
a day to the Lord and another regards it
not if you're going to regard a day do
it to the Lord so I'd say that if if
Christians are going to exploit
Christmas time for witnessing and for
remembering the gift of God to the world
there's certainly no flaw in that we
should be intelligent that you know it
probably didn't happen in the month of
December let alone the you know the 25th
of December and there's Bible reasons
for that and and you know if again as
you said anything that's not of faith if
the person feels uncomfortable about it
then and there's no command to do it
then don't do it by all means you have
that j i the verse you're referring to
Jeremiah chapter 10 and it's verse uh 3
and four yeah why don't you read that it
says uh for the customs of the people
are futile for one cuts down a tree from
the forest the work of hands of workmen
with an axe they decorate it with silver
and gold they fasten it with nails and
hammers so that it will not tumble uh
they are upright like the palm tree they
cannot speak they must be carried
because they cannot go by themselves do
not be afraid of them for they cannot do
evil nor can they do good now Jeremiah
there is talking about the custom of
taking a tree cutting it down making an
idol didn't even have the branches on it
anymore they made an idol they plated it
with silver and gold and They carried it
around and they prayed to it it wasn't
talking about Christmas trees so it's a
stretch when people say that it was a
common custom for them to make Idols out
of wood and gold and silver you can read
that in Daniel chapter 5 that the
Babylonians were praising their gods of
wood and silver and gold so um that's
all he's talking about um so if I wanted
to get together with family I mean and
there would be nothing wrong with it so
I think the only reason I felt
uncomfortable was because I thought
because when I said my mom studied with
the the witnesses that it was prohibited
and you know you know I'll never forget
yeah I I I studied with Jehovah
Witnesses it must be 35 40 years ago uh
when I was a baby Christian they were
faithful about going around and they
came knocking on our door so I said sure
you want to study the Bible come on in
and so they you know they gave me
several studies and and I heard their
studies on you know very sincere but
they did the studies on the Pagan feasts
and and it is true that the 25th of
December Springs from a pagan origin in
that date um in the northern hemisphere
you know the days keep getting shorter
until the 21st of December and then you
notice them getting longer the 25th and
so a lot of cultures celebrated the
birth of the son and years ago
Christians said hey maybe we can reach
the pagans if we'll tell them that the
birth of the son is really jesus'
birthday and they sort of comingled some
paganism with Christianity there now I
don't Advocate that but I think well
when you're living in the world Paul
said I become all things to all men I
might reach some for Christ I remember
singing Christmas carols at this Jehovah
Witness home we didn't know they were
Jehovah Witnesses we were there singing
carols they opened up the door little
kids were looking out and they said we
don't believe in Christmas they slammed
the door and I thought well that's not
the that's not such a wonderful witness
for Jesus to just say we you're singing
about Christmas cars we're going to slam
the door and say we don't believe in
Christmas so you know I think that if
you're going to do something do it to
glorify God don't have anything to do
with the Santa Claus and the you know
the Pagan
trappings anyway we do have a book we'll
send you called um baptized paganism
we'll send you a free copy if you'd like
Carol thank you all right thanks for
your call the number to call is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book called
baptized paganism we'll be able to send
it to anybody who calls and asks you can
also read it for free online just go to
the Amazing Facts website our next call
is Brian and he's listening from South
Carolina Brian welcome to the program
yes sir thanks for having me how can we
help you tonight yeah well my original
question was on Revelation uh 39 but for
some reason the spirit took me elsewhere
so uh basically I wanted to know where
did the Rapture Theory come from or you
know how did it begin when Daniel
chapter 7 you know lets you know that
the Saints of the most high you know
will be woring out for a time and then
you know in second Thessalonians when
they mentioned that before the day of
the Lord yeah I think your your call
just popped off so where did the origin
of the um where did the origin of the
Rapture come from you want us to talk
about that for a moment yes sir all
right the uh first of all the idea of us
being caught up in the air when Jesus
comes goes all the way back to 1
Thessalonians 4 when it says the Lord
himself will descend from heaven and we
will be caught up to meet the Lord in
the air the idea of a secret Rapture is
a fairly new doctrine uh the Bible ible
does not teach it's a secret or a
surprise when Christ finally does come
he does come suddenly and he comes like
a thief but it says when he comes like a
thief and this is now see second Peter
chapter 3 the day of the Lord will come
as a thief in the night in which the
heavens pass away with a great noise the
elements melt with fervent heat the
earth and the things in it are burned up
so when the Lord comes like a thief life
does not go on for seven more years so
when the rapture takes place the big
debate that Christians have in the
denominations you've got some that are
called your post-trip your mid-trip your
pre-trib they all agree tribulation
happens when does the tribulation happen
is it before the Lord comes and catches
us up during or after Pastor Ross and I
and many ancient Christians uh are in
the group that believes the tribulation
happens first uh the Bible says he that
endures to the end will be saved and God
does not save us from but through
tribulation the idea of the secret
Rapture was originated by Francisco rera
a Jesuit priest he wrote it to fight
against what was happening when the
Reformation took off and so many people
were leaving the medieval church and um
uh that later was adopted by a pastor
named Darby and then adopted by Pastor
named scoffield you've heard of the
scoffield Bible and then how Lindsay
using the scoffield Bible he printed his
book the late great planet Earth and it
made the secret Rapture Doctrine very
popular along with the Left Behind books
by Tim Le so you uh it's it's a fairly
new doctrine it's not what the apostles
taught the idea of a secret rapture we
have a book free book we can send you on
that too yes the book is called anything
but secret and talking about the second
coming of Christ and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book called
anything but secret thank you Brian
appreciate your call next call is Gina
listening from um real Linda Gina
welcome to the program thank you so much
hello Pastor Doug and Pastor John uh
please my question is about Luke 21: 25
and 26 and regarding the solar eclipse
uh coming next month a lot of people are
talking about it and wow I don't believe
it to be the end of the world I do
believe we're definitely in end times
and so please I was just wondering if
Luke 2125 and 26 tie into that at all
yeah the Bible talks about their and
Pastor Ross you have those verses you
want to read I do yeah Matthew chapter
21 ver sorry Luke Luke 21:25 I had it
here I was just looking at the wrong
book uh and there will be signs in the
Sun and the Moon and in the stars and on
the earth dist stress of nations with
perplexity and the Sea and the waves
roaring and men's Hearts failing them
for fear and the expectation of those
things coming upon the Earth for the
powers of heaven will be shaken now some
have wondered this there there's another
eclipse coming they they come every few
years this one is unique in that it is
going to basically transect North
America from Coast to Coast with a full
eclipse that doesn't happen very often
but it has happened many times before
and a matter of fact I'm thinking of
going to visit one of my kids that lives
right on the epicenter of one of the
full eclipse spots and U just take a
look at it in history they often looked
at the sun being darkened as an omen of
bad things coming most of all that is
talking about what happens before the
second coming when it say The sun will
be dark and the moon will turn to blood
the Stars will fall from Heaven this is
talking about a great Cosmic changes I
don't think it's talking about your
regularly scheduled solar eclipses some
may see this as an omen from God but I
don't think God sets his calendar base
on astronomy after this Eclipse there'll
be another one someday it doesn't mean
bad things are always going to happen
when there's an eclipse thank you so
much all right hey thank you very much
appreciate your call we got can we do a
call in two minutes yes we'll have Gary
listening from North Carolina Gary
welcome to the program we have just a
few more moments left I don't know the
exact verse but there's a scripture that
talked about a uh a sin unto death and
there's a sin not unto death and I was
just wondering if you could if one of
you all recall that if you could kind of
expound on that and I'll go ahead and
listen to you on the radio God bless you
yes I think the verse you're referring
to is first John 5:1 17 you want to read
that for us yes all unrighteousness is
sin and there is a sin not unto death
and the next verse is one I think he
wants oh let me get that one he's
talking about the sin that you uh don't
pray for that is 1 John chapter 5 verse
16 that's actually the one before if any
man sees brother sin a sin that is not
not unto death he shall ask and it shall
be given uh him for life and that sin
not unto death there is a sin unto death
I do not say that you should pray for it
yeah now the only sin that cannot be
forgiven According To Jesus in Matthew
12 is blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
and uh it's unforgivable every other sin
is not unto death because it can be
prayed for repented of covered by the
blood of Jesus and so I think here he's
really talking about the unpardonable
sin John is using some uh unique
language in descript desing it there but
um we do have a book we can send you if
you call and ask for that our recent
caller and it's called Beyond mercy and
it says what is the unpardonable sin if
you'd like to get a free copy of that
just call us at 800
83567 47 listening friend we're coming
to the tail end of the program we still
have some important announcements to
come but I just like to remind you if
you're enjoying this program we know
there's always some new listeners let us
know send some support you can do it so
easily online just go to
amazingfacts.org drop us a note there
God bless you pass on the good
word thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith-based Ministry located in
Sacramento California
amazing facts began in
1965 with a god inspired concept hello
this is Joe Cruz and the amazing facts
broadcast facts which affect you each
radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every Walk of Life
the program was an instant success and
the ministry soon began expanding to
include Bible lessons in 1986 amazing
facts added the medium of Television to
its growing Outreach efforts offering
Soul winning Evangelistic messages for
viewers around the world in 1994 Pastor
Doug Bachelor assumed leadership of the
ministry adding the Bible answers live
call-in radio program and new ministry
TV programs began airing on multiple
networks around the world for 50 years
the driving vision of amazing facts has
been the Bold proclamation of the
Everlasting gospel and with a team of
evangelists circling the globe and
thousands of men and women being trained
through the amazing facts Center of
evangelism program AFCO the ministry is
helping God's Church see a Rich Harvest
of
souls amazing facts God's message out
our
[Music]
mission if you'd like to enhance your
study of God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800 835
6747 or visit our website at amazing
fax.org did you enjoy this program make
sure to tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more Bible answers
live honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]